este es el paisaje de severodonezk tras
haber vivido una de las batallas más
sangrientas en la guerra de ucrania
entre los restos todavía viven unas
pocas miles de personas que han
resistido durante la ofensiva rusa
ciudadanos que están viviendo bajo
condiciones de precariedad muy graves y
que apenas cuentan con los servicios más
básicos
la situación aquí es dura casi toda la
infraestructura de la ciudad está
destruida vivimos sin gas luz y agua
desde mayo
estamos contentos de que esto haya
terminado y pronto tal vez comience la
reconstrucción y podamos volver a una
vida más o menos normal nueve y media
normalmente pero la normalidad está
lejos de llegar aunque es cierto que la
tranquilidad ha vuelto tras el cese de
los combates y la retirada ucraniana la
guerra ha hecho que se reaccionen los
alimentos y que muchas familias tengan
que vivir en la calle antes de la
invasión esta ciudad contaba con 106 mil
habitantes ahora solamente con unos 8000
la mayoría de ellos ancianos y personas
vulnerables que no pudieron huir
y
no tenemos pensado irnos estamos en edad
de jubilación y nos cuesta cambiar algo
pero vivir en el piso en el que vivimos
ahora es duro porque hay que repararlo y
restaurarlo
a pesar de la resistencia ucraniana
rusia continúa avanzando en la región
del donbass y tras la toma de ese verdon
jets los combates continúan en la
localidad del issys ansa